last question today hey David why do
some of these foreigners on YouTube
obsess about American politics I'm
thinking of Sargon of Akkad and steven
crowder why aren't they talking about
the politics in their country instead of
riding the wave and talking about
American politics well you answered your
own question riding the wave so the
people that are being referred to Sargon
of Akkad is a British gentleman who's
actually named car I know him as Karl
Benjamin but he goes by Sargon of Akkad
he's British he talks a lot about
American politics that's true steven
crowder I believe is American by birth
but he mostly grew up in Canada the
question about whether he's really more
Canadian or American is more of an
academic one than a real important here
and now question but the question sort
of answers itself which is a lot of the
countries that speak English are much
less interesting politically
internationally this doesn't mean that
they don't have interesting internal
politics Canadian politics matter a lot
to Canadians British politics matter a
lot to folks in the United Kingdom but
this is a money grab and it's a way to
get attention right I mean you talk
about American politics the United
States has 340 million people who live
here or however many this is a
relatively wealthy country so if people
want to support your commentary on
American politics they are more able to
do so in terms of income and I'm not
talking about just the countries Canada
UK and the US there are more people all
over the world that are interested in
American politics than are in Canadian
politics or British politics so they're
doing what's going to get attention I
also I mean quite frankly if I lived in
Argentina and I did a show I was born in
Argentina that's the relevance I don't
think I'd be doing a show about American
politics I do a show about American
politics because this is where I live
and I'm most in touch with what's going
on politically here and it affects me in
a much more direct way than it would to
do politics of whatever other place if I
lived somewhere else it doesn't seem
that interesting to me to follow the
politics of the United States and do a
show about it so you
I really have to ask them I know that
Carl has been asked why does he talk so
much about Trump maybe I don't even
remember what he said I haven't seen one
of his videos for a long time actually
I'm unsure if he's even still on YouTube
I know he was kicked off of some
platforms I don't even know it's really
a question for them but to me it's just
that it's the audience you get much more
attention talking about American
politics than you do about Canadian or
British politics on a global level
within those countries there are lots of
popular domestic policy programs and I
think they're just going where the money
and the attention it's proved me wrong
if it's something there's some other
reason then I'd love to hear it and if
they're just gonna say well American
politics is agenda-setting globally so
even in another country you're still
very much affected by American policy
okay I mean it's kind of feels like a
very much mealy-mouthed milquetoast
response but okay that that can be part
of it let me know what you think
explains the focus on American politics
by so many foreign youtubers and online
personalities we've got a great bonus
show for you today get access to the
bonus show instantly by becoming a
member or a patron